*bruits d'impatience*
- Euh...
- Papa, laisse Phil un peu gagner,
c'est la première fois qu'il vient à la maison.
- C'est peut-être un jeu...
[...]
[froid] : Mais on ne joue pas avec la langue française.
[autoritaire] : Tu joues.
*bruits de lettres de Scrabble*
[susurré] : - Euhhhh... Non... *hésitation*
[gêné] : Je vais passer mon tour et je vais changer mes lettres.
*bruits de lettres de Scrabble*
- Ok. A moi, donc,
je mets trois lettres, je rajoute "GER" à "MANIE", ça fait "GERMANIE",
22 points, mot compte double. A toi.
*bruits de lettres de Scrabble*
*lourd tic-tac d'horloge*
[hors champ] : "Linoléum"
[autoritaire] : A toi.
*lourd tic-tac d'horloge*
*coucou d'horloge*
[Générique de fin]
*imitation de bruit de moteur + conversation*
*imitation de coup reçu*
[...]
[joyeuse] : - Oh, Kennedy !
[joyeuse] : - Ouais ! Haha !
Allez, à toi, mon chéri, fais-nous découvrir quelqu'un !
*lourd tic-tac d'horloge*
*coucou d'horloge*
[Générique de fin]